think back to a perfect cup of morning
coffee feel your mug warming your hands
awake imagine the sun how it rises over
the mountains just out the cafe's back
window the birds they're chirping now
isn't that nice on days like these the
world as far as you can see it is in
picture perfect harmony ah but now let's
consider this you order your coffee with
an ounce of milk but instead get a
splash of political upheaval outside
protests put frankenstein's mob of angry
villagers to shame prisoners are killed
by civilians rakes turn to pitchforks
pitchforks turn to weapons war is all
you can think about where did that
picture-perfect morning go where are
those birds where are you you're in a
place where god is leaned on more than
government but where people are governed
more than god could even know but how
did you get here you might wonder what
political events led to this cluster of
chaos but what if the answer wasn't all
in a memory or historical record but
rather on the end of your index finger
yes your index finger that flimsy little
digit that's capable of oh so much it
points to which donut you'd like this
morning it draws in the air as you do
math to calculate how much to tip the
cashier it flicks off those pesky yellow
sprinkles you still believe taste worse
than the rest and it hails for a cab
when you're feeling too full to walk
home but you thought its role in the
course of history ended there somewhere
between picking boogers and pointing at
shooting stars never did you imagine
that that finger could turn everything
into this you're at your computer and
instead of reading the long block of
text before you you decide simply to
wonder what am i consenting to with this
innocuous click of the mouse but never
do you dare to put in the effort to find
out end user license agreements are
blind handshakes a deal is struck not by
one side's neck for negotiation but
rather by the other side's propensity
for neglect to humans reading the fine
print is more a phrase than an action
we've all heard it said but have you
ever seen it done from making the bed to
mowing the lawn history is ripe with
chores to complain about but what is
unique about this chore reading end user
license agreements is that it's met with
no resistance no moans or grievances
it's not pushed under the rug nor
procrastinated it's an anomaly in itself
it's simply ignored not how you ignore
the noise of construction out your
bedroom window at seven in the morning
that type of ignoring takes a specific
effort a pillow thrown over your head
and pressed into your ear not how you
ignore late night cravings for ice cream
in bed that takes discipline we are not
talking about an instance that forces
upon us an act of discounting but rather
an anomaly that by nature is disregarded
scrolled by thought nothing of and let
it be known that end user agreements do
not have the ego of humans they do not
take our indifference to them personally
in fact they welcome it reveling in
their anonymity while most ula's agendas
are widely understood to protect
software licensors in the event said
software crashes a computer an unusual
end-user license agreement scp-2221
has higher ambitions this contract is
not concerned with mitigating a few
lawsuits it aspires to more as you
scroll lower and lower it subtly seeks
to manipulate the minds hearts and souls
of millions and millions more this
endless scrolling asked of you is by no
mistake instances of
scp-2221 most often found by consumers
of inexpensive or free software are
longer than most end user license
agreements designed to lull us into a
zombie state out of reading but of
completing the task of reading this
particular kind of contract is so
tedious that you no longer concern
yourself with the minutia between point
a and point b you just become obsessed
with reaching the finish line and it's
within those moments of illiterate
impatience that
scp-2221 knows to strike first leading
with a jab better known as clause 189
which reads you agree that all worship
prayer absence sacrifice oaths requests
for guidance and or intervention and any
other invocations of divinity directed
at any deity or deities listed in
appendix h-8 will instead be directed at
serene tribune friend of the ranches
hereafter referred to as amicus
furthermore you agree that this clause
supersedes conscious intent with regard
to the direction of the aforementioned
invocations of divinity then as cp 2221
follows with an ever formidable clause
191 you agree that friends of amicus llc
may access your consciousness for the
purpose of exerting subconscious
influence and or temporary control of
consciousness for a period not to exceed
72 hours during any one week period but
scp-2221 doesn't stop there not before
delivering one final blow the knockout
punch clause 216
you and friends of amicus llc agree that
any attempts to breach or modify the
terms of this agreement or to bring suit
against friends of amicus llc must be
settled by arbitration in the serene
tribunal and once these clauses are
combed over and you hit agree your free
will throws in the towel surrendering to
scp-2221
and yet the battle has just begun but
first it must be asked how do you fight
when you don't even know who it is that
you're fighting who is enforcing this
contract pro tip if you don't know what
to do with your hands in a fight it is
never a bad idea to put your guard up
and that's what the foundation first did
when word got out of
scp-2221 strict containment procedures
were put into effect websites believed
to host instances of scp-2221 were
isolated for examination and civilian
users were immediately blocked from such
websites a team of c-class personnel
were then assigned to the job of
maintaining an ongoing search for
websites and software that required
users to agree to an end user license
agreement and thoroughly examine all
such agreements for signs of scp-2221
c-class personnel spend hours a day in
front of computer screens scrolling
through the tediousness of every end
license agreement they could find it was
a never-ending job like picking up trash
on the beach only to return the next day
to find high tide has brought more but
at least a beach cleanup gives a
fleeting feeling of reward to cherish
and cling to there is a moment where the
sand looks uninhabited cleansed of
pollution there is a moment where the
sun sets over the horizon and you can't
help but think you contributed a small
part to its beauty but grinding away at
the computer scavenging for harmful
clauses and e-ulas is far more taxing
than picking up trash you don't need to
toil over a littered candy wrapper to
know to toss it in the garbage
scp-2221 however isn't recognizable at
first glance each end user license
agreement took c-class personnel several
minutes to analyze before being able to
categorize them as safe or harmful
imagine a beach cleanup where every
piece of trash must be sent to the lab
before being thrown away
that's the task that was placed upon
personnel and thus they eventually came
to realize their efforts to be futile
with strained eyes and carpal tunnel
syndrome they officially aborted their
original containment procedures
understanding that the punches coming
their way were too much for any two
hands to block now while analogizing
scp-2221 to a boxer throwing blows might
be convenient it only distances us from
the truth of the matter
scp-2221 is far more dangerous than any
right hook it does not stop for the bell
it is an onslaught stuck on repeat with
a defensive stance deemed unsuccessful
the foundation had to pivot its approach
they had to change the way they saw the
problem and sometimes the best way to
learn about a predator is to study its
prey civilians who have accepted the
terms of an scp-2221
agreement are considered 2221-1
and it's in putting these 22-21 dashes
under the microscope of analysis that
the foundation began to find answers
this wasn't the foundation's preferred
method of study as they would have
rather experimented within the confines
of their labs for reasons of safety and
secrecy but they struggled to
effectively and accurately carry out
tests to resolve their questions
certain classes of individuals like
mentally incapable people and
prepubescent children are all unaffected
by scp-2221
even if they hit agree the foundation
believes this is because they lack the
legal capacity to agree to a contract
beyond that individuals incapable of
understanding the contract such as those
who cannot speak the language in which
it is written or sleeping persons made
to press the button to agree to the
contract are also unaffected by the
terms of the agreement these limitations
have proven extremely disruptive when
attempting to study scp-2221
after all you can't get too far along
with your research if your lab rats are
blessed with impunity and so the
foundation moved deeper along their
chain of proverbial lab rats and they
extended their research to d-class
personnel the d-class was instructed to
read and agree to scp-2221
this too however gave them no return on
their scientific investment the reasons
for d-class personnel's resistance to
contractual obedience is uncertain but
that doesn't stop them from speculating
the foundation however had little time
to wonder their strategy to untangle
this mess just led to more knots and
they needed to straighten things out
this time to do so they decided to move
beyond lab-driven research and focus on
studying populations who have possibly
been exposed to scp-2221
when observing populations with
frequently recurring 2221-a's
the foundation noted many odd yet
consistent behaviors first they
recognized increased voter turnout and
political activism people in passing
wouldn't talk about sports but instead
propositions and ideas elections weren't
just days of obligations marked on
calendars they were anticipated with
enthusiasm their dates were etched in
the minds of the collective as if no
different than the super bowl or new
year's eve the foundation noticed
populations dense with 2221 dashes had a
palpable energy it was like the end user
license agreement gave them a motor an
engine for action if there were social
or political issues on people's minds
they weren't just accepted as
consequence of society they were fought
for cars were just as likely to be
stopped by protesters as they were a red
light politics in these areas were
primitively efficient the system was
more condensed people wanted something
and they did what they had to do to get
it there was no room for the performance
of good manners in this political
construction if something was seen to be
out of line it was pushed back in
churches began sprouting up like weeds
because while political involvement
increased steadily the authority of
religion ran rampant a shift in practice
was observed and it didn't take a
microscope to see it religion was no
longer held in the heart hidden beneath
personal belief but it was a statement
worn like a designer jacket it was a
code for living a code that 2221-8s
believed must be enforced and so when
civilians deviated from religious law
community punishment came with it it was
not uncommon to see sinners being shamed
at the center of town squares it was not
uncommon for them to be ridiculed and
guilted until they felt like nothing at
all and while showered with shame they
stood frozen like a statue erected to
remind others of what happens when they
deviate from the law of god but even
humans playing statues weren't enough to
quench
2221-a's thirst for religious art these
highly affected communities were noted
also for their paintings from the murals
and churches 22 21-8 dense populations
glorified nooses and patterns resembling
nooses with unnerving frequency even in
the artwork that emits nooses you will
notice the necks of the subjects are
slightly red and scratched presumably to
symbolize rope that had once been there
even if not there now in affected
christian communities you wouldn't find
records of jesus nailed to the cross but
instead hanged by the neck however when
observing the work's creation the
foundation noticed that the paint
strokes of their studied subjects were
not that of an artist but a puppet there
was no noticeable muse guiding their
hand on a path of creative discovery
there weren't even any pauses for
reflection or wonder the movements were
precise but not inspired the arts seemed
to be comprised of all wrist and no
heart so if these people really are
puppets forced to perform the question
remains who is our puppeteer to find out
we have to follow the strings wherever
they run and pull and luckily that isn't
too hard as all of them lead to the same
instance october 2012 when a densely
populated 2221-8 community in a small
town further referred to as
pop-044-221-a
undoubtedly exposed themselves as living
under the influence of an anomalous
force immediately recognized as scp-2221
in october of 2012 armed mobs attacked
foundation installations in the town
site 614 swiftly contacted the o5
council to report the incident it was
believed that these mobs were not just
violent brutes looking to smash glass
but that their attacks had a more
nuanced motive soon it was apparent that
they had inside information concerning
the foundation and they demand that the
foundation surrender several specific
anomalies and mandate that 34 specific
members of foundation personnel to be
put on trial the october attacks were
initially attributed to the republic of
letters a group of foundation employees
who believe that the public deserves to
know the truth about what they do the
group quickly claimed responsibility for
leaking information leading to the
disaster at this point the foundation
was not yet aware of any major 2221-8
populations let alone pop 2221-a and
thus the republic of letters claims were
believed at least until there was good
reason to question them examination of
computers at site 614 revealed that many
personnel had been using software
hosting an instance of
scp-2221 the consensus within the
foundation then shifted to the belief
that the leaked information came from
foundation personnel having been
subverted by the friends of amicus the
group behind scp-2221
it remains unknown whether the failure
to find and report this instance of
scp-2221 was due to negligence or
deliberate sabotage to find out site-614
personnel were detained for examination
field agents from site 115 and site-621
were sent to the affected area under the
command of site director susan pritchard
to observe and report on the local
2221-a population pop zero four four two
two two one under the manipulation of an
anomalous end-user license agreement
2221-8s go to war with local prisons and
while we call it a war they might call
it a fight for justice because in their
mind this onslaught is justified but
justified might be the wrong word here
it implies logic but there is no
discernible reasoning here when
pop04221 ambushes the cells of criminals
it's not for a reason but rather an
obligation it is an order from elsewhere
these attacks don't look mechanical or
robotic yet there is a clear sense that
buried within an impassioned rage is
something enforcing it the 2221 dashes
might be best compared to horses running
a track surely they are by nature
powerful animals who enjoy high speeds
would they really act like this if not
for the contrived structures of the
kentucky derby so this is to ask who
runs the fastest the horse in the
freedom of the fields or the one being
whipped the answer presents itself to
local security as they go head-to-head
with the violent determination of
scp-2221-a's
led by their anomalous commander it was
a taxing battle but the security forces
were able to repel most of the attacks
and limit the damage however prisons in
the area didn't have such luck and were
overrun by fervent mobs prisoners at
both locations are dragged outside and
murdered even those prisoners who have
committed the most minor of crimes
college students peer pressured into
petty vandalism found themselves
sentenced to death by the hands of
2221-a's over the course of the next
four months even more drastic changes in
the religious practices of the local
sunni muslim majority were observed
local mosques began announcing the call
to prayer eight times per day instead of
the traditional five decorative nooses
were seen hanging in the doorways often
adorned with colorful cloth in elaborate
patterns several imams believed to be
instances of 2221-8 are noted to add an
additional prophet sadiq to the
traditional islamic list of prophets but
when pressed for additional information
on sadiq these imams act confused and
they deny knowledge of any such name by
april 2013
affected communities began sounding the
call to prayer up to 30 times per day
with little time left for other
activities attacks on foundation
installations ceased pop
04221-8 distributed print versions of
the
scp-2221 contract thereby converting
nearly all adult members of affected
communities into instances of 2221-a
the foundation acted quickly field
agents quarantined towns inhabited by
pop zero four four two two one dash a
and unaffected civilians were evacuated
into foundation custody the frequency of
22 21-8 calls to prayer continued to
increase until prayer became constant
among the entirety of pop zero four four
two two one dash a between may 24th and
june 6th every known member of pop zero
four four two two one dash a expired
from exhaustion and dehydration bringing
the outbreak to a tragic end the scp
foundation was one of the organizations
listed to clause 217 along with the
federal bureau of investigation the
republic of letters and several other
groups of interest and governmental
organizations personnel who have read
clause 217 were isolated and kept under
examination the addition had no
discernible effect least of all a
literal one it is believed that clause
217 is merely a taunt rather than an
infohazard or legally blinding addition
to the document however supervisors are
to make weekly reports of the behavior
of foundation personnel who have read
modified versions of clause 217 being
turned into a murderous religious zealot
is one thing being forced into an act of
unpleasant self-coitus is quite another
now go check out scp-029 daughter of
shadows and scp-053 young girl for more
anomalies that'll drive you to do
terrible things